vous qui six mois j'ai pas compris le
coup de gueule de sofiane parce que
c'est donnant donnant cette histoire en
fait eux ils se sont servis de la star
qui a 20 ans voire une autorité là la
star se sert d'eux pour fêter les 20 ans
de l'émission en plus ceux qui ont
encore une actualité musicale ça leur
permet d'avoir un peu de promouvoir
beaucoup trop beau c'est quand même
énorme après que sur tf1 et en plus ce
que je comprends pas c'est que sofia moi
j'ai appelé la production il sera dans
les prime nation en astarac d'un
surcroît il sera là oui madame ben moi
aussi j'adore ce film mais le problème
c'est que là je trouve que et c'est un
peu mauvais de sa part parce que par
exemple si on quitte le collège par
exemple moi j'ai 31 ans je n'ai pas
voulu ce traitement pendant 15 ans
j'ai pas vu mes camarades pendant
pendant 15 ans mais on fait un truc m'a
bien sûr qu'on va être potes on a beau
être temps de se revoir mais ça fait 15
ans qu'on sait pas même si tu étais pas
fan des approches article voilà aimé
mais jamais je ne vois pas le rapport en
fait c'est chouette pour eux et je pense
pas que c'était des faux bernard montiel
tient alors l'hypocrisie et la télé vous
ça vous connaît
ouais y dit les mais oui bien sûr que
ces hypocrites ça dépend de la cote
d'amour elles dépendent du succès que
vous avez c'est ça c'est tout c'est vrai
vous avez du succès alors là tout le
monde vous adore retrouve formidable
comme vous en ce moment ça va pas durer
sûrement
j'avais 12 ans va maintenant
[Rires]
au top et non mais le succès dans toutes
les entreprises
non je suis d'accord avec bernard sipié
mais je préfère le débat de bernard
montiel votre débat donc la suite
laissez parler votre site il il est
beaucoup mieux je trouve que bernard
montiel a beaucoup plus restreint mais
rien n'est encore venu dire de la merde
c'est un petit coup de gueule parce que
j'en ai marre qu'on qu'on crache tout le
temps sur le monde de la télévision moi
je travaillais à tes besoins depuis 25
ans et j'en ai marre qu'on dise que
c'est que de la merde si t'aime pas la
télévision casse toi
à vie d'ayem c'est devenu renault non
mais arrêtez de dire que le monde ne
doit pas trop
si le monde de
la télévision ça fait 25 ans que oui il
ya des hypocrites que williams et ya
aussi des gens super il ya aussi les
enjeux si je suis étonné ses pieds il
adore alors non je suis d'accord ce qui
est des gens très bien excuse moi ils
sont comme les ânes qui reculent tous
rangs fondamentaux nommé notoriété ont
tellement qu'on t'aime plus on te dit
des hommes de declan de tourner ce que
moi et
anime et en plus à la télé il ya un truc
qui est quand même énorme c'est que le
courage c'est parce qu'ils étouffent
chaque match à le dire en face qu'ils
pensent à gérer le feront ils ont
tellement peur de prendre un bourre-pif
que les deux frangins vais te le dire
mais je vais me tuer dire ce que je
pense de toi t'as vu mais j'en ai mal à
les servir quand même pas nommé dans les
grandes boîtes
la différence qui est vrai valérie moi
quand j'ai arrêté l'émission là pendant
pendant un an
j'avais zéro sms et appartements
d'étaples est chimérique par des gens
temps
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
sur des émissions sur des choses sur des
prods et tout ça comme par hasard le
carnet de déjeuner c'est ses rangs
benita des habitations ses lunettes bien
qu'il trouve forcément très gentil
batellerie négociations les trésors
signé valérie vous verrez comment
s'arrêter j'ai travaillé en qualité de
vidéo
et du tout et où j'étais
je connais des chaussettes en cuir est
il a raison il m'a collé je venais des
chaussettes en cuir jean luc holtz à
cézac ont signé l'accord mais je peux
vous dire que j'avais jamais prospéré ah
oui ça marchait très bien c'est vrai
bolide en chaussettes en cui cette
entrée en
veillée magnette
les choses
et jean luc hees temps pense à moi je
pense qu'ils sont sincères je crois
qu'il ya un truc qui se passe c'est que
au bout d'un moment si tu as partagé des
trucs intense avec des rythmes bas comme
dit exactement moi et que le temps je me
souviens que des bonnes choses ouais
c'est ça c'est ça et je pense que la
mémoire et c'est quand même dans une
histoire d'amour mais c'est comme quand
damon et céramiste agi d'une émission de
télé quand la rover dias était peut-être
moins bien que ce que je pensais le
cerveau fait que dassa coutu garde que
les meilleurs moments et ils ont vécu
des moments intenses je pense qu'ils se
sont frites et pendant la star ac mais
je pense qu'ils s'étaient sentis mais
sur la télé tu trouves que dire ce que
dit benjamin cantat plus d'appels tout
ça
c'est difficile on fait des métiers
publics et on a besoin des autres pour
travailler donc évidemment que si
j'étais un petit peu moins dans la
lumière on t'appelle - ça c'est
évidemment je suis d'accord aussi avec
valérie cd schéma qui se produisent dans
tous les six mois violent c'est mon
regard des remontées nano c'est très bon
mois 37 ans c'est pas une compétition
d'année télévision moi je te dire c'est
un moment quand j'ai été viré je peux te
dire personne ne m'a jamais ce que
je viens à temps je me suis amusé les
gens qui n'ont rien
aujourd'hui des chaussettes en cuir le
toit brûlant que vous cherchez à léry tu
parlais de télévision valérie mythique
pas la télévision c'est mon métier je
laime c'est pour ça que j'y suis je te
dis ça par deux volontés
celle ci au solo je ne compte sur
personne donc je ne suis pas déçu mais
je veux quand tu te barres de la télé
quand tu es plus dans les lumières avais
tu n'existe plus c'est tout et c'est pas
grave il faut le savoir je veux
quelqu'un qui est d'accord avec bernard
montiel d'accord avec ben alors oui
rires vous pouvez donc en effet les
riches ça n'a rien à voir avec les
autres surtout quand vous je prends la
télévision centre et de tous les vices
chez l'être humain et la notoriété de
pouvoir l'argent le sexe le succès aux
évictions sacré
[Applaudissements]
c'est sa semaine jusqu'à samedi minuit
l'arrivée à li na mais voilà c'est fort
cette évolution ça crée des relations
dégueulasse quand tu as tout m'intéresse
à toi et qu'en tu as rien t'es une merde
elle a mérité a été géré a dit donc non
mais vous voulez pas m'entendre parler
mais quand même j'allais dire tu reçois
jamais dire la même chose que valérie
genre ça du tout la politique vous
pensez que c'est l'île aux enfants ça va
mais alors on parle
jean chevais avocat les médecins qu'ils
y six semaines mais n'ont pas non mais
vous parlez des travaux que des
chanteurs ça rien à voir c'est le même
s'il aimait le showbiz mais c'est un
monde de requins il faut le dire valérie
c'est un monde de requins des ambitions
nous les ambitions sont des culs bien
sûr il ya très peu de glace où il ya
très peu cruel et donc vous mes frères à
tous est satisfait on est prêt à tout
pour piquer la place de l'autre
sur les kids resserré à falun ouais
cette fois son caractère huawei a est
très gentille ah ouais
ça va toujours pas mieux
[Rires]